i believe in entrepreneurs and it's my
mission to help as many entrepreneurs as
physically possible i love helping
entrepreneurs there's something in me
that i just can't get enough of helping
entrepreneurs out it's the feeling of
helping somebody but also
the work that you're doing is important
you're going to change your own life
your family's life your friends lives
your community's life your people in
your country
it's important work and it needs to
continue and i'd love to be a part of
that
when i had my first business i i
struggled i
i sucked as an entrepreneur and most
people do most people fail right eighty
percent of entrepreneurs will fail
i made every wrong decision you could
make
i was too ashamed and embarrassed to ask
people for help i didn't know how to
look my friends in the eyes and and tell
them what i was up to because
i wasn't making what i thought i was
going to make i was making 300 bucks a
month
not enough to to survive
i didn't know who to ask i didn't know
what to ask i was lost i thought i had
tried everything i read the books i read
the magazines it said do these three
things gonna be successful i did those
three things a hundred times and nothing
worked and i wasn't getting the momentum
that i thought i was gonna get and i had
a great product and i had a great team
and i was doing something important it
wasn't just some fly by night trying to
scan people out of their money
the product i had meant something to
people
it just wasn't taking off
but i pulled through
i beat the odds
through modeling success through finding
mentors by following specific strategies
that worked by keeping on my hustle
by not giving in even when i badly
wanted to i made it through
now i've made it my life's mission to
help as many of you as possible follow
my path i want you to jump on my back
follow my strategies and i'm going to
guide you towards success i'm going to
pull your hair guiding you towards
success because
the world needs people like you
the world needs successful entrepreneurs
and i want to help make as many as i can
over the past decade i've helped over 20
million people through my website and
youtube videos
and
it's been great it's been the
one of the things i'm most proud of
that i've done in my life i love doing
it i love answering your questions i
love helping you
but increasingly i'm getting people
writing in to say evan this is great but
i need more i need more details i need
specifics i need how-to's i need step by
step i wish i had you for two hours to
come over you know sit on my my couch
and guide me through this problem
and i really wish i had that time too
because i love doing it there's nothing
that brings me more joy than than
helping an entrepreneur and seeing them
make a breakthrough moment
but i don't have that kind of time
nobody does it's not possible
and so i've created another solution
something that i'm really proud of
something that i hope will change
a lot of entrepreneurs lives and have a
major impact
in the small business community and it's
a new product that i've created that i
call zuga
and zuga is your guide zuga is here to
help you solve
all the main challenges of your business
if you are trying to figure out
what business to start you don't know
what passion you have what how it could
turn into a business is a zuga to help
you if you're trying to get to the point
of survival
i'm not talking about making millions
i'm talking about not having to take a
part-time job i'm talking being able to
do your business full-time and make an
income from it
there are zuga's to help you
if you want to build a marketing machine
if you want people to know your name and
come and find you instead of you going
out all the time trying to reach people
there are zuga's to help you
if you are trying to manage your time
you're tired of working 80 hundred hour
weeks and you're not seeing any results
you're not seeing any momentum with your
business nothing real nothing tangible
there are zuga's to help you and if
you're trying to raise capital from
banks from angels from friends and
family from venture capitalists there
are zookas to help you every zuger that
i've created is your guide to solve a
specific problem
and it comes from me having
faced that challenge
and not knowing what to do and feeling
like i tried everything and not working
and it's how i accomplished it and then
it's guiding you step by step on how to
do it yourself
if i sat down with you for two hours to
solve the problem this is what we would
go through
and i'm really excited to put it
together in a product for you to be able
to affordably purchase
and make it work for your business to
start seeing some results
with each zooka you're going to get
advice from famous entrepreneurs and how
they solve the problem how they overcame
that challenge you're going to get
samples and templates and checklists of
things to do step by step every single
step you need to do
to solve that problem and start
realising some success
i'm so proud of it i'm so happy to
launch it because i know it's going to
help a lot of entrepreneurs make a huge
impact because what you're doing is so
important
the stuff that you're working on is
immensely important and needs to
continue i don't want you
to give up or quit because you didn't
have access to the right resources you
didn't know what to do next and you gave
up
the companies that come in to see me the
products the services the entrepreneurs
that i meet
have so much passion for what they're
doing you guys love what you're doing
right you should if you're an
entrepreneur you should love what you're
doing
and you have such great creative ideas
that can really make a difference in
this world and i want to be a part of
that badly i want to be a part of seeing
your company become massively successful
and changing the world and having a huge
impact and providing an amazing life for
you and your family that's what being an
entrepreneur is all about and if i can
help you get there i'm going to do my
best to do it
so i hope you'll check out the zookas i
hope you'll apply it to your business
if you buy one of them and you're
filling it out and you have questions
let me know i'm here to help i want to
see you be successful and i believe in
you
as an entrepreneur
belief